like the Starks the blood of house
Bolton runs back to the first men
singers call those times the age of
heroes a mask for a savage world that
bred savage men
the Lannisters swindled their enemies
the storm Kings hammered them and the
Starks cut off their heads in such
company as this with the Bolton's really
so indelicate unlike some other houses
my ancestors owned the Bolton words our
blades are sharp they passed down not a
Valyrian greatsword but a knife honed
and thin enough to fit between the
topmost layer of skin and the tissue
below and appeal for as we all learned
as children a naked man has few secrets
a flayed man in those dark days they say
that some of my more willful forbearers
would even wear their enemy's skins as
cloaks but now such tokens remain if
they ever existed certainly not hanging
in some secret room in the dreadfort as
old wives and fools insist I suspect my
hearse itself was responsible for
spreading such rumors in the first place
few weapons are as effective as terror
and this was an age of war House against
House brother against brother the iron
men were on the rise and never far from
our shores we must have seemed ripe for
the taking too busy fighting each other
to deal with the Raiders as they
deserved
thus the Starks took it upon themselves
to unify the north under them they drove
the Pirates out of white knife and claim
the eastern coast and married the marsh
king's daughter for the neck a stark
wrestled for bear island and won
or so they say silly stories blood and
steel on the north and the Starks had
the most of both after years of war my
ancestors gave up their barbaric
practices and bent the knee to their new
kings thus has Bolton became what we are
today
loyal bannermen and staunch ally to the
Starks and the second-greatest house in
the north